Good Morning everyone. Thank you for being here.
Really appreciate everyone showing up and having, uh, some
great interest in, uh, what we're here to talk about today.
My name is Michael Barris. I'm a product manager with OCI
MulticCloud,
and I'm gonna be joined in a little bit by Pat Bangalore and Jeremy
Shearer from our, our Oracle Alliance team at AWS
and Avinash Singh from our, uh, one of our customers,
Equifax.
So we're gonna be talking today about Oracle
database at AWS.
It's been a little bit over a year since we announced limited
preview at AWS Reinvent 2024
with one featured, one service in one
region, and we've been pretty busy since
then working with our launch customers and partners
to get the service built out, robust, tested,
and ready for all of our customers.
We launched generally available this summer in July
with two major service offerings in 2 regions,
each with 2 availability zones,
and we've continued to be busy ever since then. So we've
launched support for terraform,
autonomous recovery service, AWS
key management service integration,
channel partner private offers to, to allow you to
purchase through your partners,
and a whole lot more coming, including 20 more regions
that we've announced. They're gonna be coming in the next year
or so with some even sooner.
So what is Oracle Database and AWS?
Well, this partnership
between Oracle and AWS
brings Oracle database services
running on Oracle hardware,
managed by Oracle Cloud infrastructure,
sitting in AWS data centers
and available to connect to your. Applications
and services
running in AWS.
You purchase it through the AWS marketplace.
You connect it to your Amazon VPC,
and you get great low latency connectivity between
exitat hardware running in AWS data centers.
Really great revolutionary thing that we're doing
and a really wonderful partnership between our two companies.
So why did we do this? Well,
our joint customers came to both of us over the
years and they said,
we really
need a few things from you. We're, we're bringing
our workloads to the cloud. We're really excited about
the benefits and the capabilities that we get in AWS,
but there's some workloads that we just can't bring yet. There's
some workloads that we can't migrate.
What do we need to, to,
to accomplish that? Well, we need the full
features and capabilities of Oracle Exadata
and Oracle real application clusters.
We need low latency connectivity because we can,
we can do that on premises. We can do that in another
cloud and connect across interconnects, but
these applications need to be very close to the databases
they talk to,
especially for chatty mission critical applications
where every microsecond matters. And so
running them within AWS data centers allows
them to connect really easily and closely
to your AWS application services.
They told us they wanted a seamless experience, so they didn't
went to some IP address to some black box
that they can connect to.
They wanted an integrated experience where they're purchasing
through AWS Marketplace.
They're provisioning using AWS APIs
and and CLIs and console and tools,
and they're integrating directly with things like identity
and access management,
um, cloud trail, cloud watch, and that sort of thing.
And most importantly, they wanted to be able
to bring their enterprise data
to native AWS services and allow
their workloads running on EC2 and ECS
and EKS and Sagemaker Sagemaker
and all these great services
allowed to access
their Oracle database workloads and so that's what
we've been working on for the last year.
So I'm gonna use a customer journey as sort of an example
of, of, uh, to talk through some of the capabilities
of the service and how it works. And
so let's say a customer like Equifax
is moving to the cloud, they've got workloads that they
need to migrate, and they've got these mission critical databases
that they haven't been able to move to the cloud. And now with the Oracle
database at AWS they're able to.
There's kind of 3 big steps in this journey for them.
First, they're gonna work with us through the AWS marketplace
to purchase and subscribe to the service.
Second, once they've got that subscription up and running, they're
gonna actually provision A Oracle
AI database resources into their
AWS account.
And then once those services are up and running, they're gonna
bring their data and unify it with their
services running in AWS. So let's kind of walk
through that
and see how this works.
So first of all, they're gonna subscribe to the AWS
marketplace. This works through a private offer.
So you're still gonna work with your Oracle account team
to put together an offer based on your commitment
and consumption and estimated usage over
the next year or so.
They'll help you work and put that private offer together and then you'll
purchase it through the AWS marketplace.
And you can purchase it either directly
or as a channel partner private offer through one of our great
software integrators or ISP partners
that are really key
in a lot of customer migrations.
You'll pay AWS if you have spending commitments
with AWS this will count against that.
And you'll get great flexible licensing options.
If you want the best elasticity, you can use license
included and just pay hourly for the license fees
and get all the bells and whistles and capabilities of Oracle
Database.
If you've already made that on-premises licensing
investment, you can use bring your own licensing with great
license portability options
and optimal licensing metrics. So,
you get the same licensing metrics
that you have in OCI or on premises.
That's half the license requirement
of running on VCPU-based licensing and authorized
cloud environments. So there's already some great opportunities
for cost savings.
And you'll get access to OCI and Oracle database
services running in these AWS data
centers. So, so let's look at what some of those.
Oracle database services are and it's all built on
Oracle Exitata.
Exitata is the hardware and software platform
that Oracle has built over the last 12 or so years
to be the best place to run Oracle database. You
can run Oracle database on your own servers,
you run on virtual machines. There's a lot of ways you can do
it, but the people that built the software said,
what can we really do with hardware after the Sun Microsystems
acquisition to really be the best place
to run Oracle database? And so
we've built. Data intelligence software and hardware
where the the hardware knows what a database is,
it knows what a database extent is, it knows what your
data is, and it can work seamlessly
together with CPUs and storage and
CPUs on compute nodes
to give you some of the best performance, the best availability,
the best scalability
in the industry. And of course
it's the exact same exitatta hardware
that runs anywhere else you wanna run it, so you can run it
on premises with cloud at customer
or an OCI
or in our multi-cloud environments.
On top of that Exitata hardware, we built the Exitata
database service on dedicated infrastructure. So this
is one of the key services in this offering.
With Exitata database service,
you're gonna subscribe to physical
hardware dedicated to your use,
starting at 2 compute nodes, 3 storage
nodes, that's about 400 CPU
cores and 240 terabytes of storage.
You need more than that, just add more compute nodes, or
storage nodes, 80 terabytes at a time.
Build out a cluster how big you need.
So Oracle is gonna own and manage the infrastructure
itself. So this is again Oracle X data hardware
sitting in AWS data centers managed
by Oracle,
managed by Oracle personnel.
We're gonna manage the hypervisor, set everything up, configure
all the networking, all the RDMA,
all the hard parts of running rack,
and, and getting everything configured and put
together for you.
Customers are gonna subscribe at the VM cluster level,
so you'll, you'll deploy VM clusters that
divide up your dedicated infrastructure, however
works for you and whatever suits your need. You could have
one big VM on each server that contains
all the CPUs and memory. You can divide them up between your
prod, dev test workloads. You'd have
a bunch of different workloads running in there. And then
within each VM cluster, you run your container databases,
within those your plugable databases.
Once you're inside the database,
the customer owns everything. It's your data, it's your schema,
your encryption keys, everything inside the database is yours.
Oracle personnel can't access it, AWS can't
access it. Great security model here.
Everything is managed by you inside the database.
Our second major service offering here is built on top
of exitata. This is the autonomous database service.
An autonomous database on dedicated infrastructure, one
of the really cool things here is that you get the flexibility
to run both
exitata VM clusters and autonomous VM clusters
on the same dedicated infrastructure. So you get
to decide how to divide it up and what services
you want to run on top of it.
Autonomous database gives you a fully managed database
experience where we've taken care of all the,
the, the infrastructure as well as the
performance tuning, the configuration.
Um, in the operation of the database, and, and
Avinash is gonna be talking a little bit about how Equifax
has chosen and benefited from autonomous database
and the capabilities that it brings. So you just
tell us what kind of workload you're running, whether it's OLTP
or data warehouse and how many CPUs you wanna run
it on. We'll take care of tuning, set
the SGA PGA,
configure the database to work for your workload.
As your workload shifts, we'll adjust tuning parameters
to accommodate that,
and we'll grow the database for you and manage that configuration,
patching everything else under the covers for
you. And
then the third major service that we have as part of this offering
from OCI today
is the Zero Data loss Autonomous Recovery Service, which
is a bit of a mouthful, but if you've used
the zero data loss recovery appliance on premises,
this is again where we've sat down and figured
out what's the best way to back up an Oracle
database to provide you the best protection,
the lowest impact during backups, and
the greatest recovery options. And so,
Um, this again runs in AWS
data centers, allows you to keep your data in AWS
and backup using the greatest capabilities. It's
a really, really neat capability here where, where we take one
full backup when you start and then everything is incremental
from there.
When you do a point in time restore, it's, you're
not worrying about, you know, layers of, of, of incremental
apply on top of each other. You just tell us when you want to
restore to, and the service is gonna take care
of synthesizing whatever
state the blocks all need to be in to get you back
up and running.
All right, so those are the capabilities that we have that
you, you'll subscribe to through the AWC
marketplace.
How do you actually
make use of it? Well, you're gonna provision it
using the AWS management console,
APIs, CLIs.
Cloud formation, terraform.
You're gonna integrate with the capabilities of identity
and access management,
connect it to your VPC,
monitor host metrics and cloudWatch.
Send audit to cloud trail when you perform service
operations.
Encrypt data using transparent data encryption.
It now supporting AWS KMS
and you can even back it up to Amazon S3. So
again, this isn't just some IP address or a black box
at the end of a of an interconnect. This is a service
deeply integrated
with our, with our partners at AWS.
Now you'll,
again, provision X data infrastructure and VM
clusters into your AWS account. And I,
this is a really simplified architecture,
but I, I, I think this, this diagram, uh, there's
4 things I like to call out about this.
First of all, right in the middle
is your Oracle AI database services.
So exit data database service and, and autonomous
database. Living again
in an AWS data center in
an availability zone. We'll tell you the zone IDs
where these are located and you can provision those into your AZs.
The second is that this connection back to OCI
region. So this is a managed service operated
by Oracle Cloud infrastructure and so our control
plane in a nearby region using high availability,
redundant links
is gonna connect to the, the services running in
AWS and operate the service for you.
The third major thing to call it is the ODB
network here. This is a new AWS construct
that allows you to contain
logical settings for networking for your databases.
It's a lot like a VPC,
but it can only contain Oracle database and AWS
resources, and it can't contain an internet gateway.
You'll access services by peering it to a VPC,
and that VPC can of course contain things like transit gateways
or cloud WAN
so that you can fan out to broader networks.
And then the 4th thing is
the applications. That's the whole point of being here is to run
these database workloads
against AWS services and applications.
And of course, that's a simplified diagram.
We can get really complicated with this.
We support
maximum availability architecture, gold certified
configurations.
This is an example of a cross-region replication,
but you can set up cross AZ replication. We're
gonna be two AZ's everywhere we operate.
You can be cross AZ and cross-region.
Um, and all this replication is just a matter of clicking
a few buttons in the OCI console to enable data
guard, data guard replication. You can also
manage, uh, a fast start failover if
you want the highest levels of availability.
Now how do you get your data into this? Well, it's an Oracle
database.
So the, my favorite answer to this is however
you move data today. If you're already, a
lot of you know, DBAs already have practices built
around data pump or export or
you know, logical migrations, you're already moving data
around in your infrastructure a lot today. So,
the first answer is move data however you're
already moving data if that's what, what's already working
for you. The second answer is gonna be Oracle zero
downtime migration.
This is a utility that, that we offer that wraps
around a lot of those capabilities like data
pump and export, and RMA and
Dataguard, and even Golden Gate,
which you can use Golden Gate for logical replication into
OCI database services license-free for 6
months. So a great capability there.
We can connect to just about any source database,
just about any source platform,
and migrate those workloads
to Oracle Database and AWS services.
It's essentially just a binary that you download.
Again, it's gonna wrap all those capabilities. You'll
tell it what kind of migration you want based
on your criteria. So do I need an
online or an offline migration? Is, is downtime
really sensitive to me or can I do this
over a weekend?
Is this gonna be a physical migration or a logical
migration? Now with exit data database
service, you have access to the host, you have sys
DBA access, so you can do RMA and, and
data guard-based physical migrations.
With autonomous database, you don't have host
access and you don't have sys and sys DBA access.
So you're gonna do a logical migration which can integrate
data pump and Golden Gate to still get, get
you a really low, close to zero downtime
migration.
And then 3,
you've got these database services up and running. You're now,
you have databases in AWS
running on exit data, running on the autonomous
database. Your,
your business data has been migrated,
and now you've got the best of both worlds. You've got your, your,
your world class
exitat database services. You've got
your business data, you've got the capabilities
of AWS, and you can bring those all together
to get deeper insights, build more scalable, reliable
applications,
and reduce your management overhead. You know, the great thing
about managed services.
Is you, especially in this AI
era,
your data is the most important asset you have and
increasing in important value every day. Your
DBAs
know where your data is, where it's moving, who's
accessing it, how it needs to be secured.
They really should be working on, on things like managing
that data and integrating it with, with your
new AI capabilities and services
and other applications rather than troubleshooting backups
or patching operating systems or figuring
out why, you know, a, a failover didn't happen.
Now, you also get access to the
latest version of Oracle AI database
because this is essentially Oracle cloud infrastructure
under the covers. These are OCI managed database services.
So as we come out with new versions of Oracle Database,
it's gonna be available immediately in Oracle
database and AWS.
It's a whole lot of new features that I'd love to talk about, but I
don't have time for that. So there's, there's one
example that I like and, and uh I, I know y'all haven't
heard enough about AI this week, so I thought I would use an AI
example. So, with 26
AI we've added a new vector data type.
As we start working with AI a lot, one of the
things that becomes really useful is vectorizing
our data. A vector is essentially a mathematical
representation
of complex attributes
of data
that can be generated by an LLM
and then stored natively in the database.
Once we have data represented mathematically,
we can now really easily
do operations. The, the database compute engine really
loves math, it's very easy to do.
And we don't have to worry about more complex things than that.
So you can add a vector data type.
You can generate embeddings, store those in the database,
and now you can get the benefits of LLMs,
um, just using SQL. So, so
here's an example.
So let's say you've got a database that contains a
bunch of rows of data that describe houses for sale,
and there's all these sorts of attributes. There's a number of bedrooms
and bathrooms and construction type and build
time and
what school district it's located in, how much your HOA
fees are.
If I'm looking for a house with 2 bedrooms in a
particular school district that's kind of new construction
and maybe I want,
you know, a certain kind of roof.
Building that query can be really difficult. I can search for
all those attributes,
but I'm probably gonna leave on the table things that are similar
to those houses, but maybe don't meet all my
checkboxes. Maybe it's, you know,
right next to a really great school district, but it's, it's,
you know, 1.5 bedrooms or a bedroom
in a den, or, or maybe it's a, it's an older
house and I want a new construction, but it meets a lot of my
other checkboxes as well.
I can take all those attributes from those rows of data. I
can embed an LLM
inside the database with 26 AI if I'd like to, or
I can use a service like Amazon Bedrock and call
a Titan model
and have it generate vector embeddings, and my
application can just store those in vector columns in
my database next to the, the, the, the
existing product data all in the same place.
And now doing that query is just a matter of, of a
vector distance order by. So select rows
from this table,
order by vector distance.
Of an embedding vector for my search
terms
and this column of vectorized data.
And now we can use the benefits of LLMs to and
natural language processing to find the
closest matches really, really simply
without having to replicate my data elsewhere, without having
to have a separate vector store, without
taking on the headache, the security pain,
the, the governance overhead of
maintaining multiple data stores for the same data.
Of course, there's a lot of other capabilities of Oracle Database
26A.
26 AI. I'd love to talk about them all,
um, but hopefully that gives you a sense of what you
get when you get access to the latest
features of Oracle Database
running on Oracle hardware managed by OCI
sitting in AWS data centers. We'll have some resources
to link to at the end and of course,
um, our, our documentation and product pages
can get you going and a lot more information,
um, and we're, we're always happy to talk more.
So now I'd like to turn it over to um Jeremy
Shear and uh our AWS partners.
Hello. So
Jeremy Shearer, I'm a partner solution architect
here at AWS in the Oracle
Alliance team. I'm joined by Pat.
Yeah, I'm Pat Bangalore. I'm the, uh, partner development
manager, uh, looking out for the alliance
with, uh, Oracle. Uh, I'm
an AWS alliances manager as well.
Yeah, OK.
So to recap something that we just
talked about is this offering
has been rolled out to two regions already,
Northern Virginia and Oregon, and
we've announced 20 additional
regions around the globe. Some of them are going
to be coming very soon,
some of them may be a year or
so out with that.
These regions are being deployed with multiple
availability zones. So in Northern
Virginia and Oregon, we've both deployed
with two availability zones, and you're going
to see that pattern continue
as we're rolling out the service globally.
So from a foundation perspective, just
to come back, which a lot of the people in this room
already know about, is the definition of an
AWS region is a bit unique to
Amazon,
where we define a region as
having multiple availability
zones, and that is the basis for
how we approach high availability
at Amazon.
So
these availability zones are
geographically separated from each other
and meaningful distance, so if an
event happens in one availability
zone, it's unlikely to
impact the other availability zones,
but they're close enough together that
latency is often not a,
a, a problem,
you know, across them.
So, now how do we apply that
with Oracle database at AWS?
And how do we do high availability using
the Amazon concept of high availability?
The way we approach that is we deploy
NEA data into the first availability
zone. And then we use data guard
replication to synchronously
replicate the database either with maximum
protection mode or maximum availability mode
to replicate that database
to a second availability zone.
So that gives us a no data loss
configuration.
Some applications are a bit more
latency sensitive.
They they can't even handle that level of replication,
that sub 2 millisecond replication.
They may change into a maximum performance
mode and replicate asynchronously, but
the preferred pattern is to do synchronous
replication between these two availability
zones.
We'll then deploy a 3rd
in the 3rd availability zone, a
data guard observer to
support fast start failover,
to monitor those exits
in the other availability zones, detect problems,
and help arbitrate and manage
an automatic failover between
the two exits
if it's needed.
But this bottom part of the, the chart
here is just half the picture. That's the database
part of the picture, the MAA Gold architecture
that we talked about earlier.
When you move up the stack, you need to make sure
the top side of the stack is equally configured,
highly available.
So in this configuration, we would deploy
the application tier
across multiple. availability zones
and we'll typically use an AWS
application load balancer to distribute
the load among the application tier,
you know, detect if there's an anomaly in
one of the availability zones and redirect
the traffic to the remaining availability
zones to give you a complete
application and database high availability
pattern.
One of the reactions to this
is, hey, that looks expensive. You're
telling me I need an exit data in the 1st availability
zone, an exit data in the 2nd availability zone,
and oh, maybe another exitat for disaster
recovery.
Well, there, there's a lot of capabilities to
control cost in this solution. One of the key
capabilities
is we can run that 2nd exitata
in a pilot light configuration
where we only turn on the CPUs
that we need to manage that replication.
These Oracle databases support
online scaling, so you can turn up
the CPUs when you need them during a failover
event or during a DR event to
help manage that calls.
You can also deploy in a rack
single node configuration. You don't have
to do multi-node rack on these exaat.
You can deploy on a single
instance, and that is another way to manage
the calls.
So the takeaway from this is this is a robust
architecture and it doesn't
have to break the bank to deploy it.
Once you have this, the
Oracle database of AWS deployed,
you can actually take advantage of our over
200 services that integrate
with it. Up on the screen here, we, we
have several of the services that tightly integrate
with ODB at AWS that we use often.
S3 backups is on here. You can do the,
you know, the automated backups of ODB at AWS
2 S3. That is an option. You,
you see terraform and cloud formation on here.
Those are completely baked into the solution
for automated provisioning and configuration
management.
I'm gonna dig more into
the AWS Resource access
Manager. I'll be talking about
our observability,
and I'll be talking about KMS
on the upcoming slides. I'll dig more into those.
So. So
again, when we talk about, hey, we're going to deploy
this architecture in an MAA gold pattern,
we have all of these exitats, that is a
lot of horsepower we're deploying.
You know, each one of these exitatas has 240
terabytes of storage, 380
cores, 2 2.7 terabytes
of RAM.
Not all of your business units need that
much horsepower to run.
So with AWS Resource
Access Manager we can actually share
this Exadata infrastructure
across multiple AWS
accounts in our organization.
So you can have your manufacturing
organization running their own exadata
instance on that underlying hardware
and that underlying hardware is then shared with the retail
operation running, you know, customer databases and your
logistics operation managing
the truck deployments.
Most customers are going to have some segregation
between production and non-production. Different
AWS accounts to do that. That's also
supported here where you can mix and match
those, particularly when you're looking into
that multi AZ configuration. A
very common pattern we see
is that people deploy the non-production
on that MAZ, the the secondary
AZ
node or the secondary AZ exitatus.
So once you have this scaled out
to your organization, you need to
think about securing it. And how do you secure
this at scale with all of these
database clusters across all
these different AWS accounts? And the
answer to that is AWS KMS,
the key Management Service.
So with AWS KMS we can manage.
Oracle TDE keys, transparent
database encryption keys directly
inside of KMS.
So no longer do you have to have a separate solution
to manage your application encryption keys from your
database keys. You have a
single consolidated solution
to manage all of your encryption in
one place.
So you, you now have it deployed
highly available across your organization.
You've, you know, shared it with resource
access managers, so different entities
within your organization can leverage it. You've secured
it with KMS.
Now you're running and operating it
with AWS CloudWatch. You
can actually see the metrics
inside of the exa data in your. Cloud
watch dashboards, you can see the CPU
and the disk IO and the different
performance characteristics right
alongside all of the metrics that are emitted
from your application tier and,
and
reduce your your mean time to recovery
when you have an event to actually see
what is happening
within your system all within the
same dashboard.
So, I was given just a few minutes here to
talk about some of the, the services that
really excite me. I'm gonna hand it over
now to Pat Bangalore to talk a little bit
more about the AWS and Oracle relationship.
Pat. Thank you, Jeremy.
So Michael Barris during the
initial slides talked about the partnership
and the alliance,
and the reason why
Larry Ellison and Matt Gartman stood on
stage and had this partnership alliance stitched
together
is because of these reasons.
And if you look at this alliance, this was born
out of
clear customer need. When you look
at 90% of the Fortune 100
companies are running AWS.
And then close to 87%
of customers are running.
Exit datas, whether they are on premises
or clouded customer or in some way, shape
or form,
exit datas are ingrained.
Within customers for various
workloads,
whether it is application workloads or analytical
workloads, data warehouse workloads, and so
on and so forth.
So what we are seeing here is
customers have got
Applications deployed on AWS
they've got large databases
running on exit data on premises,
and they reached out to us saying that
how do we get this together? We want
these applications
closer to the databases,
and we want them
within the AWS data centers,
and that's exactly what we did
and that's where this partnership and alliance
took place
where we're able to roll in.
Exit data racks inside
AWS data centers to offer low
latency, high throughput
for the chatty applications that you all have.
I want to quickly talk about.
Support
On the support side
this is a collaborative support so the
partnership does not end
just with
feature functionalities
co-engineering innovations,
and you know some of the other aspects
or features that we wanna bring to our customers.
One of the key aspects of this collaborative
support is to start looking at what are some of
the technical limits,
what are some of the billing limits, and
then how we help our customers.
From a technical standpoint,
if you have an issue with ODB and
AWS or anything related to
the connectivity of the applications within
AWS,
the first point of contact would
be my Oracle support.
So you open up a service request with
Oracle
or
have our AWS technical
account manager
call Oracle's duty manager
to open up a support request.
OK,
and make sure that you have
customers have the OCI tenancy will have
a customer support identifier. You'll have the CSI
and all those jazz, so you should be able to get that.
So on the billing side,
customers start in AWS support right
from a billing because this is being transacted
as a SAS private offer
through AWS Marketplace,
so the billing occurs on AWS.
So make sure that if you have
got any issues with AWS
billing, the first line of
contact would be our customer
solutions manager or technical account manager
from AWS side.
Helping you out on the billing constructs.
OK, now if it is something on the
OCI side, if you're not able to
look at it, you wanted to get some details
done, then certainly our
technical account managers would contact
the duty managers from Oracle to open up
a service request and then start
triaging the uh uh the problem.
So that is how we uh
try to segregate between a technical
limit and the billing limit
process. On the
issues of onboarding, obviously when you get
into an onboarding of AA data, you're
going to go through the private offer. Michael uh
explained to you how the private offer scenario goes
through and all that.
You won't have a CSI number assigned
to it. So at that point in
time you would use the toll-free
1-800 number to contact
Oracle
to help with a customer support identifier
or
maybe have a duty manager help you through
this process,
bringing in Oracle experts to resolve that
issue. OK,
so it's not just from a technical
aspect of co-innovation, but
we also have collaborative support.
And on the next side I want to talk about
business.
So I know Michael and Jeremy really
touched upon a lot of things on the technical
features and innovations.
Let's talk business. Let's talk dollars
here for a second, OK?
So a lot of folks here might know that you're
key influencers
in the procurement process
in understanding, uh,
you know, PPA drawdown and commitments. So
I wanna bring this to you
that.
From an ODB and AWS standpoint, if
you're gonna be migrating assets
from on-premises to AWS,
we do have the, the famous
migration acceleration program
funding mechanism.
Where it is not just the funding mechanism
for assess, mobilize, migrate, and modernize,
we also have tools and technologies
and resources that we have built in as
part of map program to help you
seamlessly migrate your workloads
from on-prem to cloud.
OK.
The second aspect is when
you have a private pricing agreement
with AWS.
Which is formerly called as the Enterprise
Discount Program,
where we provide you with a list of discounts for
using AWS services,
plus we also provide you with AWS
credits and so on and so forth.
In return,
customers like yourselves would have commitments
with AWS.
So those commitments can
now be fully eligible at 100%
for ODB and AWS consumption.
Now, even though this goes through the marketplace,
there is a 25% cap
for ODB and AWS consumption.
That cap does not exist. That's
been removed for ODB and AWS.
Again, ODB and AWS consumption
is at 100%
for all your commitments towards your
PPA,
right? You can draw down your PPA commitments through
these consumption.
The second aspect is what we introduced
in October of last, uh, last month
is, uh, the,
the channel partner private offer
CPPO. So this is for SIs
and, uh, systems integrators and
ISPs and distributors
who wanna resell
ODB and AWS
to your end customers.
So you own the billing.
Right, the SI owns the billing and
controls the billing and resells ODB
to your end customers, so you can do your migration,
you can do your manage services, run
and maintain,
plus the billing aspect. So it'll be a single throat
to choke. It'll be one single bill that
you want to give to your end customer.
So,
partners
who have a PPA with AWS
through the channel partner private offer can
retire
your quotas at 100%,
similar to what we offer for end customers.
So direct customers can retire quota
at 100% for ODB and AWS
consumption. Channel partner
private offer, systems integrators can retire
coda at 100%
plus you've got the map incentive.
Right? So
we're trying to put everything together from a
business construct for you to make it
easier
technologically, yes, it is much more
advanced, but also from a business construct
we wanted to make it very simple and easier
for you to draw down your consumptions
towards your PPA commitments.
So I want to bring this all back together,
right? We stitched this partnership
we had this for our end customer benefit
and for our partners,
you know, we have got the full feature functionalities
of Oracle AXA data
you've got the Enterprise edition you've got
all the features of uh uh
the database that you get.
Plus you also get the real application clusters.
I know that some of our customers, uh,
uh, the joint customers use a lot of these
applications
that rely on rack
for workload balancing,
application continuity, transparent application failover,
and things of that nature. So it's great to
have,
you know, X data with rack built in
for you
and the rich features and functionalities that Michael
Barris talks about.
The second is the low latency,
right? We are pushing the boundaries here
by bringing exit data racks
inside AWS data centers
in truckloads
and then offering pink pipe and power,
making sure that it is all being interconnected
together in the same, uh, data
centers,
thereby reducing latency and
improving your throughput for your chatty
applications.
And then the whole seamless experience,
right, you've got one single bill you've
got the app tier and the database tier
running together. It is a private
offer through the marketplace,
you know, and it is a single management
console that you can provision both your
app tiers and your databases
which are residing on AA data.
And then finally leverage AWS native
services,
especially generative AI, Agent
Core, Amazon Bedrock,
everything seamlessly getting integrated with analytical
solutions with Oracle's exit data.
Now with all being said,
I'm gonna get this to Equifax
Mr. Avinash Singh, who is gonna
explain to you how
the journey for their
organization bringing in Oracle's exit data
into AWS and leveraging
their BRM application workloads for their
migration,
specifically autonomous database constructs
into their organization,
Avinash, please.
Thanks, Pat. Uh thanks, Mike and Jeremy.
Um, so there are a lot of talk about
the benefits and um
what are the use cases that we can use
ADB. So I'm, I'm gonna go ahead and talk
a little bit about Equifacts,
what we do and who we are.
And also, we'll select one of the
major use cases where we selected the ADB
at AWS.
So we are using autonomous database uh
service. Uh, let's talk a little
in the slide, uh what we are gonna go to
present and let's talk about who we are.
So we are almost 15,000 bright minds
across the globe,
supporting 24+ countries,
uh, providing that consumer services,
uh, from the credit perspective.
We are one of the, uh, biggest
3 credit bureaus in the US
and, uh, we take care of
a lot of consumer needs,
uh, uh, on the financial data perspective.
So if you see in the slide that we
have supported almost 29 million
US consumers
obtain the loans to buy the car
in 2024.
So this is the 2024 data.
Uh, 9.2 million,
almost, uh, almost user consumers,
uh, they applied for home loans and,
uh, mortgages.
So they all use that our Equifax services.
Uh,
We also add a lot of value in our
community.
So we, uh, Equifax
actually invested around 3.3
million for Equifax Foundation and gives
to the whole
community of
US and global.
Uh,
we have the verification services, uh,
quite used by the government agencies
to provide, uh, support
to the needed people, any assistance
needed from the government.
So, um,
We have done almost 25.5
million verifications for people seeking government
support. So there are a few uh
uh things that Equifax does,
and all those things are possible through that
underlying Equifax technologies,
definitely supported by AWS and Oracle.
So why Equifax? We have a
proprietary cloud
built using Equifax proprietary
knowledge base.
Uh, we mainly focus on
three major principles,
uh, differentiated data,
advanced analytic, and global insight.
Uh, differentiated data, uh, basically
make sure that it provides the quicker and,
uh, uh, and confined
data and uh
uh all those information to the consumer who are
needed. So,
basically, the data needs to be very confined.
That's why that we see that
uh products like Oracle product or AWS
product where that our data sit,
and then we provide the confined data and and
differentiated data to the consumers.
Uh, we use advanced analytics.
That advanced analytics, uh, concept
basically to help consumers
to get that data faster, whatever the
information they need for their consumer data.
And then finally, that global insight.
So, the data that has that
various attributes, right? The consumer
requires that different, different attributes
from their consumer reports,
credit reports and all that.
So these are the three major principal Equifaxs
users to, you know,
provide the services to the consumers.
So, uh, here that, uh, use
case that why we need ADB at AWS.
So, uh,
I support the global platforms, uh,
for financial services.
Uh, we are using a whole set of Oracle
products. You can name it like Oracle EBS, WCI,
OBIE,
and one of the major, uh, product is
Oracle BRM,
which is Oracle,
uh, uh, billing and revenue Management System.
This particular system is very, very highly OLTP.
We use that system for
usage, rating, billing, and
generating the invoices.
So, um,
There are several fulfillment
systems in Equifax where
we provide
several services. All those users need to interface
with our billing system, and we have
to rate those
transactions on time.
We have to bill,
and then we have to deliver the invoices on time. Otherwise,
it would be marked as a very big revenue
loss for us.
So it's a very critical, critical mission system
where that we need a very high performance
supercharged workload
to be, you know,
performed, the uh all the analysis,
all the rating,
billing, and invoicing.
So, um, that is one of the reasons
that we selected Oracle
ADB at AWS.
So if you see here that uh we have
that, uh,
key considerations for the BRM databases,
why that, uh,
we need, uh, ADB at AWS.
We have been a very uh uh good
user of RDS. RDS is awesome
product. We are using RDS Oracle.
But it has certain limitations. So, good
that it was announced
yesterday that it is having 256 terabytes,
now going to be available, but we have been running
uh with this challenge of 64 terabyte.
So, as I mentioned that we operate on around 24
countries. So all the 24 countries'
legacy billing system is migrated to our global
billing system.
So you can think of the enormous data of the billing
comes to our billing system.
So we always struggle for the storage.
So, uh, we had, uh, we,
we have hit off the 64 terabyte limitation
of RDS.
So that, uh, we were thinking, what is the
better kind of a service that we can replace with RDS
because RDS is an awesome service.
And that's what the confusion, if you see the guy
on the left, it's not like that I'm having
a trouble. I'm just thinking, OK, I, how
should I just move from RDS to ADB
at AWS because RDS is also an awesome
service. But there are
very key benefits like Michael, Jeremy,
and Pat all talked about that,
what the benefit it is going to give us
when we move to ADB.
So it's the best of both worlds. It's sitting in AWS.
It's one of the best
Oracle database products sitting
on exactata.
It's autonomous,
similar experience like that we are getting with RDS
because that our DBASs need not to uh
break their heads to maintain the infrastructure,
then database patching and all that, all
will be covered with ADB.
Which is the same, same, same experience we have
with RDS. So it's like a, a
more performance system because of the extra data
power. Uh, sitting with
AWS, so it's like, as Michael and
uh Jeremy talked about the seamless integration
with around 200 services, right?
So, um,
that we are gonna go to leverage. So, uh,
certain benefits I uh put here that
with, uh, moving this billing system
to our,
uh,
ADB, what would be the benefits?
So first is like, uh, definitely performance
and throughput. Exa data power,
everybody knows that,
how that performance it is.
You can horizontally scale how many
compute nodes you want,
a lot of cores and a lot of storage availabilities
is there. So our storage problem will be resolved.
Uh, currently that we have to purge the
databases every quarter because
of the storage limitation.
Uh, we have almost 8 terabytes per
month growth of the database. So you
think that how we sustain with 64 terabytes,
now that we have a petabytes of storage available
with the ADB. So, that is one of the major
consideration of moving to uh AXA, uh,
ADB. Uh, then
that, uh, 26 AI was announced
in Oracle AI World,
and then 23AI was existed. So
we were thinking about moving this,
our database to ADB
23AI or 26 AI, harnessing
of AI power that we can utilize.
So my data, as soon as I migrate my data
to ADB,
my data will be AI ready.
ADB comes with Apex 24,
which you can create a lot of
uh Apex forms and all that to
harness your AI capability,
which data by default setting in AI database.
So, this, this is like uh making
your data ready AI.
Right? By just doing this migration.
So those are the uh multiple benefits
that uh we seek
from ADB and that's why we started the journey.
We completed all our non-proud.
We are going live by April,
May some time frame uh with all our databases
to ADB. So,
so far, it's a very seamless journey, very good journey,
and uh both AWS and Oracle
are supporting us to
uh make this happen.
So thanks to Oracle and AWS.
Having said that, uh, Michael,
You wanna add something?
Alrighty, well thank you very much Avina. We really
appreciate that story and thank you all again for being
here. Hopefully we given you a good understanding
of what Oracle Database at
AWS is, why we've built it
and how it can benefit me, so.
I'd really like to say a really big thank you to our partners at
AWS who made this possible
and our customers for who we built this. I, I
don't know if there's a better example of customer obsession
than Oracle and AWS coming together
to build these workloads for our customers.
And again, this was really built because our customers
asked for it. So
keep that in mind when you go meet with your Oracle and AWS
account teams. Let them know what you'd like
from this service, from other services. We really wanna
hear from you. We wanna hear what we should be doing next,
where we should be going next,
and how we can better help you. We do have some resources
you can check. Out here
we do still have one more day of the expo, our booth
1767 back right corner
of the expo hall. We've got a lot of experts there that are happy
to answer any questions you have about the service,
um, and there's also the AWS database booth in the pavilion,
and of course I have to please ask you to, to fill out your session
surveys and let us know how we did.
They don't actually let us expense our lunch unless you've, we've
got a certain number of surveys in. So,
so, uh, please, we really appreciate the feedback and,
and, and it helps us understand what to talk about next. So
thank you all for being here. We do have a few minutes to answer
some questions.